now it is not only Jim Jordan calling
for the police to be defunded it is
failed former president Donald Trump yes
indeed yes indeed what am I talking
about well I will show you Donald Trump
now in the wake of his uh arrest is
calling for the federal police to be
defunded he had the following to say on
his platform truth social quote rep this
isn't all caps by the way republicans in
Congress should defund the doj and FBI
until they come to their senses the
Democrats have totally weaponized law
enforcement in our country and are
viciously using this abusive power to
interfere with our already Under Siege
elections Trump doesn't like the fact
that he was arrested by the way not by
federal prosecutors
and he is now calling for Congress to
pull funding from doj and FBI that is
that that's police that's law
enforcement that's federal law
enforcement and of course laws for the
and not for me has always been the
Republican way it's really important to
understand that when Trump says when he
talks about they should come to their
senses what he means is I should be
allowed to do whatever I want with no
consequence but nobody else should and
as I've told you before their stated
principles mean nothing oh we do we
support the police no you don't you
support the police to the extent that
it's convenient
when it came to the police officers
Capitol Police on January 6 2021 all of
a sudden they weren't the heroes the
hero was Ashley Babbitt
all of a sudden now it's not about fund
the police it's defund the police and
remember that on Sunday Jim Jordan said
the exact same thing to Maria bartiroma
legislation write laws and pass
legislation so we'll look at that and
maybe most importantly Maria is we
control the power of the purse and
that's we're gonna have to look at the
Appropriations process and limit funds
going to some of these agencies
particularly the ones who are engaged in
the most egregious Behavior so the doj
and the FBI
yeah and and what I'd really like
frankly legislation the doj and the FBI
it's not just one person anymore these
are the folks who have been slamming the
left for years saying you all want to
defund the police and I look around I
looked I looked under my phone and maybe
under my glass so why I can't find
anybody other than random voices on
Twitter who want to defund the police no
serious Democrats want to defund the
police there's no serious movement to
defund the police do some of us want to
reform restructure absolutely change
training protocol 100 percent
demilitarize of course but there is no
big movement to defund the police except
people like Jim Jordan
and Donald Trump and all of their
acolytes and suckups are now saying oh
doj and FBI we have to defund them oh
okay so when you say they want to defund
the police you really mean you want to
defund the police and what is
interesting to see is that at least for
now Republican voters don't seem to be
going for it let's take a look at that
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fumes success story head on over to
trifum.com and use the code Pacman to
save 10 percent when you get the journey
pack which comes with the device and
three flavors the link is down below